and finally new rule enough with
revisiting things stop being surprised
every time you watch an old movie or TV
show and find some of the ideas in it
are old a recent article by Molly
Ringwald got a lot of attention because
she revisited The Breakfast Club and her
other eighties movies and found them
troubling in the age of me - she said
she was taken aback by the scope of the
ugliness oh please they were teen
comedies not snuff films
she said it's hard for me to understand
how John Hughes was able to write with
so much sensitivity and also have such a
glaring blind spot no I don't know
should we dig him up and yell at him you
can't
you can't blame someone for not being
woke 30 years before woke was a thing I
remember the 80s being woke when you had
too much cocaine I think we should
listen to Lisa Simpson who last week
addressed the controversy around up who
an Indian character who runs a
convenience store because we all know
there's no such thing Lisa said
something that started decades ago and
was applauded and inoffensive is now
politically incorrect what can you do
exactly what can you do
labor us all degenerates for not already
being who we would eventually become
twenty years ago the joke's on friends
were just funny now some Millennials
some I applaud the same ones but some
find the jokes sexist transphobic and
fat shaming okay but if you spend your
time combing through old TV shows to
identify stuff that by today's standards
looks bad
you're not woke you're just a douche bag
Obama was against gay marriage until his
second term but I don't think we need to
pretend he never existed you can't enjoy
any music movies or TV from back when
for any length of time before seeing
something we just don't do anymore but
aren't we adult enough to separate what
we like about an old movie from what we
don't we can watch big as a movie about
a kid who becomes an adult and not as a
movie about a grown woman who [ __ ] a 12
year old
the most the most beloved and wholesome
act in history is the Beatles but even
they wrote she was just 17 you know what
I mean
which today sounds a little Roy Moorish
they also say I'd rather see you dead
little girl than to be with another man
and I used to be cruel to my woman I
beat her geez if all you need is love
how come they kept threatening everybody
but that last lyric is from the song
getting better which is what we have
been doing it's all you can do because
every generation could be called D what
were you thinking generation in the
early 1900's heroine was a children's
cough medicine in the 50s amphetamines
were sold to housewives as diet pills we
used to drive without seatbelts and
drink while we were pregnant and litter
indiscriminately just throw [ __ ] out the
window
we smoked on airplanes we would board
and enclosed aluminum tube with old
people and children and asthmatics and
light up a Chesterfield we had pageants
where we paraded women in swimsuits and
judge them on their appearance oh wait
we still do that yes yes and that's the
point we're never finished evolving I
hate to break it to you but no matter
how woke you think you are you are
tolerating things right now that will
make you cringe in 25 years
beauty pageants mass incarceration
putting our parents and old-age homes
how we treat animals one day your kids
will grow up and ask you what's Facebook
and why were you on it all day
what's a reality TV star and how did one
become president we can't believe people
and old movies smoked they won't believe
we put the cell phone in our pocket next
to our nuts
[Laughter]
I have a feeling young people look at
the clothes we wore in the 1980s and
think oh they had to be doing it as a
goof no we thought we looked good let me
show you a jacket I used to wear this is
real
no I used to wear it I had it no you got
turned you got a stand up a turn
I believe me finish I kept this as a
reminder to all of us
never again looks like a villain in a
Batman movie
I know clothes aren't as important as
racism or sexism but it is the same
principle we didn't know what was wrong
that's what happens in societies they
lapse into groupthink we all did this we
walked the streets looking like this
every day and it went on for years and
years and no one said anything we turned
away and we let it happen because we
wanted our shoulders to look really
really big
[Music]
so let's chill out on busting balls for
breaking rules that didn't exist at the
time the arc of history is long but it
bends away from Hammer pants just
remember in the 80s there were two top
hair stylist Vidal Sassoon and voltage
and don't even ask me about my mullet